foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
what's going on guys
you know how does the camera look
how's the camera look
yeah I personally feel like the camera
looks my entire stick that's just me
shout out the stream man
shout out to stream the latest many
people know
addict
is playing persona
move this over here
as you guys can see this is the title
screen persona what's up uh Queen Beezy
is that how you want to be pronounced
what's up Suicide Kings how are you guys
doing
oh
so as you can see I have played a little
bit of the game because I wanted to
let you guys skip a lot of the fluff uh
at the beginning you know how the
beginning of every game has a lot of
fluff in it so you know we we're
starting at the actual Palace the first
palace
I don't know what that was about
so let me turn this down a little bit
um
I I I've always loved the persona
Persona has always been a very solid
experience
foreign
okay
okay
why is it keep doing that
we're going back in here
that was uh that was horrible
is it turn based combat yes it's
turn-based combat show me your true form
but it's a unique big turn into a combat
why does this keep happening
[Music]
I might reset the Xbox
I don't know yet
let me turn
Okay so
how does the audio and my voice sound
guys got to be honest with me how does
it sound
uh did I beat scorn I definitely did not
beat score
why I'm gonna get thrown out of this
Palace
all right we're resetting we're
resetting I don't know what's going on
with this but we resetting I'm not
having this happen the entire time we
stream man we're resetting this Xbox
because something ain't right
is this all he has to spin on
PlayStation for a while you knew that
day on you knew that it's not acting
like you didn't know that
guys are setting us up to fail man
it wasn't popping up yesterday though
that was an interesting part it wasn't
popping up yesterday
a quick resume
what's going on uh Tim
man this this dude kind of kinky
got her tied up like that she a high
schooler too
what's up Donkey
I can't believe you mistook
this this dude is like the definition of
a creep
like the definition of a priest are you
afraid
I do as I please here after all this is
my castle what
wait what a lively sled oh my God man
this is this this game does show how
creepy the world can be because you know
situations like this maybe not
necessarily in some Shadow reality but
there's some creepy stuff like this
going around around the world
now then what
I didn't see that
I think uh she's I think she gets hers
here in a second I bet you
no he's a creep
he's a creep
ERS there's not many ways that you can
misunderstand that individual
enjoy the dismantlemanship oh that's
creepy maybe I'll start with the club
what's funny is uh a lot of like
Japanese Developers
they seem to love to sexualize just by
anything they can
huh
you're right letting this Beast why
don't we just attack him
what was that I mean I guess she has to
unlock her persona but why don't we just
attack him
here's her persona
well I'm waiting for this Twitter this
stream
this to go through I'm gonna go ahead
and uh share this on Twitter
[Music]
I hear you
you're right no more holding back
there you go nothing can be solved by
restraining yourself
yo it's funny too
they got her stepping on someone which
is
that's crazy man
she got the leather stuff on
a tail
yo man they they really want above and
beyond with this sexual stuff when they
made this
I ain't scared of this dude
are you in this the dude on the commode
if I remember correctly
Stop Me Now
[Music]
this dude's probably weak to fire
man
I mean your persona is in some leather
stuff I mean
that's pretty uh sexualized myself there
Anna
that didn't do anything
oh he's resistant to that all right we
ain't doing that again
[Music]
use the gun
got a little bit of his health back
we're gonna go ahead and heal no
actually not with air we got to get some
of that help but
hit her with three because skull's
knocked out
all right here we go here we go
[Music]
all right
I feel like we might be able to kill him
there we go
outside of school that guy's nothing
yeah demon toilet hello the gamer demon
toilet you guys you know how you like
the Deep the the demon totally unique
concept man I like that I'm not gonna
get them on too much with that I like
that
media an ability called media oh [ __ ]
look at him running look at him running
wait
wait what is this and where just calm
down I love how she was just using magic
and now she's questioning it you weren't
questioning when you were shooting that
fire you question it when the cat starts
talking
and we just fought a demon on a toilet
and you question the cat talking
like this when did I
oh you could say you look great oh yo I
could tell her she looks great she
clearly a little uncomfortable so I
gotta say that
she's getting fired here give me your
arm
you take the other side oh there
other high-level persona
I'm kind of curious what you mean by
that man what do you mean of the high
level persona
looks like we made it back
hey are you okay well pretty much still
not explaining how she's accepting all
this pretty easy
leave now but a lot sure did happen back
there
at any rate we stand out oh you talk
about the personas Tim do they level up
and
and change
are you talking about the people
which one you want
which one are you referring to
the people
whichever is not carbonated or the
persona
actually
the art style is good
how far into the game is this it's only
like an hour an hour into the game
here you go
uh so pretty much how the personas work
on this game is you can make new
personas by sacrificing other personas
to combine them
I'll show you in a second I've got the
tutorial on personas yet so you'll see
it here in a minute
sorry you're not a cat it's only natural
that you
you guys want me talking over the the
dialogue or
you want to read their voices for the
dialogue I can't believe what happened I
need a little bit of input on that
so if what you told me is true we can
make is it really possible
can we the volleyball team's keeping
quiet about this while teachers and
parents if guys like us try and complain
you're just gonna shoot it going all in
on this plan is the only choice I love
these um
I love the Persona 5K I haven't played
too much before but I love five
not overly slow they're uh let me
don't act like I'm going hey
she'll be great we need all the help we
could get Ryu don't worry stop trying to
say we can't take her with us we need
all the help we can get
we've been rushed out of the palace like
three times
Chic I won't let any more people I'll do
whatever whatever it takes we're gonna
win
oh yeah got the level one
oh
isn't she like the the sister of the cop
that's interrogating us in this if I
remember
guilty and misdirection
some of you might even have been hiding
behind a public face their entire
if you're listening then answer me
thou Hast acquired a new vow
it shows the birthday oh yeah someone so
talked about my uh yeah I should
probably change that I didn't change the
scorn
in the in the tags someone brought it up
let me change it now
all right
so these are pretty much like
the relationship you have with other
characters in the game
your number and chat ID and
um
I'll be counting on you then
yeah it's on Game Pass guys Game Pass
the pleasure you can experience this for
the price of your subscription
and I'd recommend you guys go do that
what a girl
you could get together true
our best option would be to make
the school roof it seems like I can't
contact you from inside a palace so I'll
stay in this I'm personally nominating
little cat you should feel honors
you there's no I love how well they're
just frequently acting like like people
would come together and choose a leader
that easily we we all know that if this
was in real life scenarios they would be
fighting who the leader of that group is
okay let's go look at my new residence
for this world
yeah I feel you
there's a
I don't think this game's for everyone
it's like I said you got to enjoy these
type of games in the first place
yes hey Leo that's the
that's the medical check
thanks yeah we don't gotta read any of
this
it took me about a hundred hours to be
we're just now she's the head doctor
all right I get it I get it I want to go
talk to her
uh it's making me it's forcing me to go
to bed unfortunately
[Music]
oh yeah you're talking about the the uh
the cat he doesn't want he doesn't want
us to have the cat I remember that
but he ends up being a softy and giving
her food after saying he doesn't like
cats
want to get us back to that Palace man
another type for those of you that don't
know we skip back to the old because
right now we're telling the story from
the future
and we come back here because this is
this is the present right here and we
keep we're talking about the future when
we go back into the actual game
she's interrogating us
we already had this persona
it's the cat's persona
not to change
electric by the way the power you used
in the palace was the stronger that
power gets
all right personas depending
yeah you gotta like these type of games
like this isn't just something everyone
will like like you gotta like turn base
first off you gotta like a a slow build
up see I'm skipping a lot of the
dialogue at the beginning because I'm
explaining the the situation you guys
because I understand that some of you
don't want to read all this dialogue so
I'm explaining the story to you
[Music]
you guys I wanted to
can I go downstairs no it won't let me
it's making me go to bed
you think she says about the book
no not yet eventually you could take
books on the subway and level up some
stuff I have played a good amount of
this I've never beat Persona 5 but I
played a good amount of persona
they're talking about the uh the teacher
right there if I believe remember
correctly maybe I'm uh I probably should
have read that
oh now this is cool when you're in a the
class first off
I think we could all agree on Modern I
don't know how modern technology is in
school but when I was in school they
catch you um with you they catch you on
your phone it's a wrap they taking that
that stuff away immediately
so it's interesting they could just sit
here
no uh low tier gamer I've played uh
I played a little bit of Royale not a
lot but I did play a little bit of it
all right they're just talking about
where the rooftop is
see right there he clearly caught us
with our phone on any and he
he gave us the option to put it away and
when I was in school
they that teacher was coming around here
and they around those stairs not stairs
around those students down the aisle and
taking my my phone from me
oh
did he just throw a piece of chalk
that's assault that's the salt and
batter
that's a salt and batter
you know after we get through at this
Palace I want to hit the teacher
he's got to have his own Palace man he
just yo this man just threw a chalk at
him I don't remember that
was that what we're calling it
daydreaming
daydreaming gets someone the right to
just throw chalk at them looks like
we're all here okay hold oh don't
underestimate
no we going in I'm
Morgana we're going in we don't need no
preparation
dang they gonna make me
no
okay so this is the one where we're
going to the uh
we're looking for the
[Music]
we gotta find the
the clinic yeah here it is
so pretty much the the reason we want to
level up the clinic because you get more
stuff and she's a she's a freak guys
I'm gonna let you guys actually hear
this one this this chick this chick's
worse than uh than the t than the the PE
teacher like her mindsets were she's not
her self-wares but she's she's
definitely she into some some crazy
stuff man her she ain't crazy stuff she
don't act on it that's the difference
like that the teacher he's a scumbag
that acts on it she doesn't
foreign
so we go in the back pretty much and
this is where she'll like you can
convince her to sell you usually just do
distress to sell you
items and you know medical stuff that
you wouldn't normally have to buy but
you have to get your guts up to get
better better ones
so which types
whichever we'll take anything right
there how about a stinky just kidding
she performing like experiments and
stuff on you it's pretty crazy I'm
guessing you
oh what's the rumors oh well I wish I
could ask her straight up what the
rumors are
who's to say
but as a result all I get are patients
with ulterior motives now oh you have
arterial motives too school kids have it
tough nowadays well fine
but only medication that will help I
guess it's fine you seem pretty Earnest
and you don't look like you'll be any TR
this is my private practice I have a
license to make my own formulas you've
likely seen them being oh various
hospitals it's your responsibility to
take care of yourself so if that's okay
with you stop by anytime
I could say she's A Bad Doctor we want
her stuff though we're not making her
mad saves me the hassle
you're a pretty weird kid
well as long as you don't
well which do you want all right so you
can't really get too much from her yet
and you don't even have a whole lot of
money in the first place
so we're gonna grab a couple of uh of
these thanks
let me turn off the notifications
because I want to get as far as I can
into that dungeon I'm going to try to
get into the to the red parts of the
dungeon off the bat
I don't care what this other dude has to
say
what's the reason for your visit
I think that's a lawyer
don't play dumb with me rumor has it
it's a drug so potent and I can give a
person unlimited power really that's
news to me developing experimental drugs
medicine and Herbal Remedies violence
all Health regulations are you
attempting to create a super stimulant a
drug like that will only become a social
issue you're really persistent you know
that I'm just a quack the police may not
be taking action but I imagine the media
will soon pick up on it
foreign
I officially don't care anymore what
these people got to say
hey man so far so good we can use that
we don't need to hear what they saying
[Music]
all right so tomorrow we go to the let's
turn in for the night tomorrow we go to
the Palace so let's go ahead and get to
the Palace I'll probably have to do a uh
a question or something
hair coming up I'll have to do
The Crossing
oh
oh they're making me do a side mission
head to Central Street I think central
Street's over here everyone wake up
Japanese
appear to be thriving they have no this
is the dude that you uh use to unlock
one of your attributes I can't remember
what should a tribute it is
I think this is you go to the airsoft
gun place here
so pretty much
you're about we're about to learn how
personas work it's down this little
hallway right here
[Music]
now we're going here because we want to
have
like
guns and stuff that look like guns uh
that actually have the effect in the
actual real world
this is pretty much where we go to buy
our equipment guns etc etc you know you
need this stuff to
uh to fight tougher opponents we're
about to see the uh personas too
oh he gave me five G's
I don't know why you gave me five G's I
can't remember oh yeah it was uh what's
his name that we don't need none of this
right now come again
later you could pretty much get through
the first one pretty easily with just
the base stuff
it's a Coke I shouldn't be drinking it I
haven't really drunk too much soda the
past couple
weeks but you know every now and then
I'll let one slide
yes you do
addict what do I need
what do I need flame explain me what I
need
oh God
click I don't need to upgrade my weapons
great
now I am going to get some some uh some
locks I don't need I don't need it
look at flame telling me what I need and
what I don't need
think he going he gonna rock like that
but you know what's funny Chad flame
don't trust me he got no faith in me
oh look at you guys you you giving him
way too much power
with great power flame comes great
responsibility
great power comes great responsibility
Flame
oh my God I don't
oh that's the chick that was at the
beginning of the game
yes he lent me a helping hand earlier
I recommend you steer clear the likes of
him if you haven't remember the
discussion we just had there are a
number of you know what's funny you get
so much shade for saving some
no trust an addict you know I don't I
don't feel that I don't feel that I'm
gonna
put it all I got I want to take him out
myself
he gave me a brief lecture that
something about the dangers I don't mean
to prop I don't care
we're going to this Palace because now I
I'm committed to seeing exactly flame
doesn't believe that I could do this
first palace without upgrading
I think I think flame is underestimating
my ability okay
[Music]
you underestimate my power Flame
yes I get it we're going to the Palace
yes we are definitely infiltrating that
Palace
we gonna do this Flame
how far you think I get in one day of
invading the palace
I'm curious to hear your opinion flame
considering you don't
you don't trust me
[Music]
all right
all right this is when they teach you
personas I guess
I remember being in the hall uh in that
Alleyway for some reason
so pretty much all he's saying here is
he's teaching you how to make new
personas that's all
foreign
yes I get it I get it I get it ogre or
whatever your name is yes let's make
that let's do it let's do it
I actually didn't want to do that
ain't nobody want to make yeah I
actually like the original personas that
they gave you
this is so kind of graphic they're
putting like
execution style things sacrificing two
things to make one persona
and that's like a weak Persona I think
we come across them in the second temple
in the second Palace I can't remember
it's been so long since I played it
yeah that's why I'm skipping a lot of
the dialogue I'm just explaining to you
guys you know what's going on because I
I don't want you guys to get over over
stimulated on the story
I want to go back
I never played Soul hikers too
[Music]
all right here we go guys
the official first day
of being in the palace we got flame over
here saying I can't do it I hear he's
saying I have to upgrade we about to see
we about to see what happens and I was
doing it again
well oh
all right so let's see come on
[Music]
tired of that man
[Music]
okay
[Music]
show me your true form fam
turn off the network stuff okay I'll
turn it off here in a second
I got you
all right I'm gonna do that after this
look at that flame didn't even get hit
didn't even get hit flame how do you
feel about that flame
how you feel about that
didn't even get hit playing
you got to tell me how you feel about
that
it's just the first one I get it
but I ain't got hit yet Flame
let's turn this off
Why didn't it turn off
there we go
oh
so I ah okay okay that was that was a
mistake that was a mistake okay okay
I'll give you that one play I'm about to
get hit a little bit
thank God it's fairies it's nothing
really like serious
I don't have curse attack
s
[Music]
there we go all right
how to make up for that man
can't believe I got hit going out the
gate
ah
now then
I'll reveal your true form
ambush
[Music]
you killed him
oh if it's on pass I remember that
the Baton Pass made you stronger maybe
not
I don't remember what that dude's weak
too
[Music]
[ __ ] cool Joker
all right past the Baton
I think he's quick to fire
[Music]
I need to start interrogating some of
these people
when are they going to let me start
sneaking up on people
I think this is where you learn
all right yeah this is where this is a
key
point of the game
we're gonna interrogate the horse this
time
[Music]
you're not over yet
[Music]
Okay so
let's just kill her
We're Not Gonna We're not gonna waste SP
on this thing
he's dead
there we go
show me money
that's all I want I want money
not trying to take Powers right now
smooth I'm just trying to steal
everyone's money that's all I care about
right now
yeah yeah yeah
I got you
come on come on come on
oh what
I'll reveal your true form
how can I get back I don't know what you
mean
[Music]
foreign
there we go
you have to go actually buy it I don't
know if you have the ability yet but you
will eventually get the ability to buy
personas okay okay
if you're still around when I go back
into that room I'll show you
what's at the bottom
bull stuff
let's go in here though
all right now
let's check the top before we go in
there
oh what happened
man that's bull
foreign
yeah eventually that will change
[Music]
[Music]
because right now the biggest concern I
have is just spending as less SP as
possible
I'll reveal your true form
that's my
initial response right now
I think these people are weak to fire
but it doesn't look like I really got to
spend much on them
they'll die without using any SP
they're pretty weak
show me your true form
[Music]
all right these people got a little bit
of power on them
I'll take the hit
I'm not using SP on them I'll take the
hit
that's fine
[Music]
not doing too much damage
nice work Team
level six
if you use the DLC personas I don't even
know how to access the DLC personas
I haven't already been here
[Music]
I think I've already been here
I'm backtracking
foreign
for this dude to turn around
I don't know uh you have to tell me how
to access the DLC once
[Music]
let's go ahead and use one fire
[Music]
we could kill the rest pretty easily
yeah see
light work man light work don't take
much
okay
that was so easy I'm yawning
I'll reveal your true form it's about
staying inconspicuous man we ain't
trying to fight too many people
go down
[Music]
do it
oh that was that was a mistake
it wouldn't take long to kill them
though
they were too weak to bother with
yeah somehow I got turned around I don't
know how that happened
foreign
I think it's in the items like my items
not really a lot of items there man
oh
I'm gonna I'm about to get hit
yeah we can't mess around we got to take
them out fast
something else
all right
there we go
oh more
Joker let's do this
yeah the UI in this game is unique
that's what I like about it it's Unique
[Music]
give me money
I don't even know what I'm saying
I got an item
I should have read the dialogue is what
is though
I'll have to read the dialogue with some
of the later personas because you don't
want you want to make sure you get some
of the other ones
foreign
it worked
[Music]
oh
we got the blueprint
[Music]
all right we gotta go the other way
he's coming towards us we don't want to
go that way yet okay now we want to
show me there we go
all right let's just shoot this one
let's switch to to skull to get the
lightning on that one
you can't
and then switch to motor for her I uh
for her win to get that last one they'll
probably kill that one though
let's get some money
that's good little good little paycheck
for now
there we go
we got a little bit of money there and
we've dropped our thing down to zero
show me your s so that's good it got
caught too much at the beginning we were
getting that uh that number up too much
for my liking
[Music]
I just kill it
we should be interrogating I don't know
why it didn't interrogate it go
maybe it's because I hid it already so
it wouldn't interrogate if you hit it I
don't know all right I'm not gonna
really argue too much about a game logic
all right so we go up here
rusted handcuffs this can't have so many
crazy Concepts
uh where are we going
okay
I did buy lock picks didn't I only only
made one
that's unfortunate I need more lock
picks
there's a safe room
okay
we made it to another safe room
you hear me flame that was directed
towards you in case you didn't notice
of us making to another safe room
[Music]
LLC is going to be a little bit stronger
I'll reveal your true form
oh I like these
I don't know what they're weak to though
okay so
okay
that's awesome
I want money
yeah give me all that money
that's all I want is money
okay
okay
I hate when it like glitches on me
I appreciate it some ball
oh
I don't remember what this shit's weak
to all right it's not that
it's not that I guess we're not gonna
find out
but we noticed that wind or or guns so
it might be like lightning or something
it's probably fire
I could see her being weak to fire
I can feel it
is he gonna come down here
I'll reveal your true form this isn't
Fall Guys not playing Fall Guys man
playing persona
say this is the thing that we just got
[Music]
yeah when
I don't think you have any skills yeah
unfortunately
and I'm going to know if I want to use
all her win to attack these three
I don't think I got much of a choice
let's just take the XP guys
[Music]
we need the XP
uh
more puzzles
see what this does
okay that scene to have worked
okay okay we good so far see what this
does
oh there's another one here
probably gonna be a trap when I hit this
one
[Music]
no it worked
[Music]
all right so let's see here
it doesn't seem like there's anyone
here but there's more of these little
[ __ ] things
how many are there there's two
let's go for this one
foreign
oh okay you're using them to open up the
other side okay
all right let's open this side
one would think you would want to go
over here towards the other side that's
just me though
all right what is this where am I going
here
oh
all right it doesn't look like it has a
uh a lock on it so I think I can open
that
hold up
[Music]
okay hold up hold up
[Music]
so shutting those but if I do those it's
just gonna shut them again
I'm missing something I'm missing
something
I'm missing something here guys
it wasn't that though I'm missing
something else
so you can get into those into that one
without
putting yourself in a bad situation
once if I reclose it like here
okay then I close it here
foreign
I've been through the duck a couple
times that I just forgot that you can
get it from that side
[Music]
uh
uh hold up
let's let's open this
foreign
[Music]
he should have saw me I don't know why
he didn't saw me chat
that was kind of bizarre
[Music]
oh wins is weakness
Wings to hit its weak points all right
so we don't know guns is a weakness
so it's not
I don't want to use wind again but
they're so strong
yeah let's just kill them
just use health-based moves on them
and miss
nah just regular attacks we're not
trying to miss
there we go
okay
we beat him
no we're using this
on them
not using health
make sure there's nothing here I can hit
like another treasure chest
so I was about to miss that
oh God oh God oh God
he's yellow too
there we go I feel like the the sneak
system's messed up a little bit
just a little
[Music]
I think
we didn't try fire on this one
yep week to fire
all right so I can't fathom why any of
this is happening can't explain yourself
I certainly hope you have a good reason
for this blender's treatment
that would take a while there's no need
to explain let's say that will take a
while would you just search just the
main points then I've heard the human
men have proactive to tease the women
there
oh my God it's possible with the series
eventually you need to be attributed to
that
fair enough
not a response I think I'm sorry I
remember now oh yeah I got her
I need to [ __ ] I don't know if she fired
I just needed another Persona because I
only had one currently
and there's an achievement an
achievement for just snatching a persona
[Music]
ah
what is this
okay it ain't seen us yet yeah let's get
him
rip that mask off
is that all
[Music]
right just beat his ass then
[Music]
that was very disappointing
[Music]
why isn't he dying
can't break
begging for life when an enemy is in a
dire situation may try to bargain for
its life enable you to negotiate with it
and possible gain one as shadowless
personality determines how it is to beg
timid Shadows are more likely to make
wow infrared Shadows won't beg quite as
often
let me get him as a Persona I need more
personas right now
I need more weaknesses
[Music]
because the uh margon or marginal calf
always butcher knife she she doesn't
have a lot of SP left so I need to stop
using her as much
all right hold up stats
ice
fire okay so I got ice and fire I'd like
to get a win one
to view the detail okay so it's an
accessory
yes oh look at that
that was that was ironic got what I
needed
what is this
all right shortcut yeah
[Music]
I think that's the grappling hook yeah
okay
is that all yeah okay that's good
let's go up
[Music]
is that all I can do
oh it's a it's a red one
all right so red ones are a little bit
tricky
it's a good thing I couldn't Ambush it
they're a lot harder if you can't Ambush
them
batting Savages have red doors may run
around to be higher levels in order to
negotiate that you would need to inflict
damage until it changes its fighting
sense at this point you can hold up
so he's level nine
what is my level
uh
so let me see here
[Music]
let's try lightning first
oh
[Music]
fire
let's do lunch
stunned
I don't think we can negotiate with them
because he's too high of a level so
let's just do as much damage as we can
because he's strong when he hits me he's
gonna hit me hard
but we're able to uh pull that without
too much damage
got a little bit of money from that too
500 dollars
I can't remember anything about this
oh you look you're farther than me
classic that's cool where are you at
like hour wise
I don't see a weak spot uh what is he
weak to I don't know we'll try one
nope
let's just kill him
we don't gotta waste for more magic
let's just kill him
we got this chat we got this
leveling up pretty good though I will
say I'm leveling up pretty good
oh book
just done Castle Palace
um
I can't remember where the castle Palace
is
maybe I never got to that
please don't be wind okay
fire
okay so you are weak to fire
she's starting to get weak she's
starting to lose that too
just try to kill him
there we go
oh you got up
yo that's very suspect you guys see
what's coming out of their growing area
what level are you five come on over
buddy
let's get another one
boss fight is a hard challenge I can't
remember
I can't remember that one man
let's get this book
I think there's three books that you
have to get I can't remember
we are starting to get a little bit of
damage though
[Music]
foreign
so I am starting to come to the uh
the end of our road
now don't get me wrong I could still go
a little bit farther
but I am getting to the point where I'm
not feeling comfortable anymore
of course it's wind
[Music]
y
let's get these three
and I think she is weak to fire
let's just get the fire one out
there we go
uh we don't have a cat one yet I don't
think we do
but you know what let's just all out
attack get a little bit more XP
[Music]
the art style Persona is something
special I really do I believe it's
something special
okay
piece of cake
all right so there's a person in here
it doesn't seem like there's oh this is
a safe room
God is a strong one
what are you gonna do
[Music]
all right so something
[Music]
oh what is that
and I'm not fighting him right now
there we go you're level 15. I think I'm
level like seven maybe eight I don't
know
um
[Music]
they're weak to fire
he's got fire
d
do I not have a fire persona
[Music]
there
[Music]
bloody knuckles glad to see you on Game
Pass and enjoyed I'm glad to see
everyone playing this the personas are
good franchise man that's why I feel
like it's important that Microsoft gets
the next one in the game in their system
they don't have to be game passed Game
Pass would be amazing uh but it
definitely the bare minimum it's got to
be in the actual system ecosystem it
cannot wait two three years it can't
even wait six months it needs to be
there day one
Shadow spotted yeah I'm gonna fight you
guys I'm not fighting you yet
I'm good on you
how suspicious how do you fast travel to
the safe house uh right bumper I believe
when you're in safe houses uh you can
fast travel like that
let me go ahead and take this dude out
probably another horse dude yeah
I don't see a weakness so he's strong
against fire
blizzard let's try that
[Music]
oh he blocks entirely from that
let's put him to sleep
lunch
I don't think I could take nine yet not
that level yet
but I'ma tear him up
[Music]
one of these had fire an ice move yeah
let's see if his eyes
oh yes tear his ass up
[Music]
oh who's he hitting oh
tried not to let him hit me man
oh
[Music]
end it
oh those red ones man they're rough
it's [ __ ] go wrong really fast
fighting those red ones
okay
tough one
see if this was worth it
a mace
all right yeah go and put it on
I wish there was more stuff here
that wasn't really worth all that
nonsense
you don't have enough you don't have
enough
uh
how far am I into the dungeon
um talk to the team
see our progression
I think this this is still the beginning
stages I don't since the treasure
anywhere near uh so you know we still
we just got a little bit further man we
got a little bit further the good thing
is we have been getting some drops doing
this
uh to help with the replenish stage so
we don't have to use magic we we're
unfortunately we are probably gonna have
to call it quits into this dungeon here
soon
because
they are man they're getting us they're
getting us pretty hardcore
[Music]
yeah I did that already earlier I put
him to sleep
did I get all three
I felt like I didn't get all three
let's see
maybe I missed one
all right so I missed that one I didn't
miss that one I just didn't get it
I mean I I you guys don't I'm I'm
jacking off
all right so I got all the books
am I missing something
um
we don't have enough
I'd have to
look
I know I don't have anywhere close to
that
I can't save and let me go into the
into this room
you could save it here
I have two hours and 37 minutes bloody
[Music]
nothing
how do I get to that room
[Music]
there's like a room
that looks like it's hidden
somehow
this one right here
all right so now I got the books
this titles for books here the tiles
don't have any rhythm or Reason to them
this book has sheena's name in the title
it's not just one all the books here are
about female students
[Music]
uh we found a book earlier didn't we hey
hey Queen book
all right let's check another one here's
another one over here
slave I think my might butcher that one
all right let's see this one
the King book
yep it worked
yeah oh
that looks weird
this room
oh he's obsessed with someone else this
dude is a weirdo man
there we go
all right so let's see here
he's creepy we get it
this is the second floor
all right there we go
it look does look like we're getting
closer to
[Music]
why did it make me attack him
I would have prefer to Ambush him
what is this
I don't remember this
oh God
oh so we can attack his butt
what's a b
itch
I vaguely remember this I think this was
added in Persona
[Music]
but we good
we got him chat
there's more
[Music]
all right
so what's our weakness oh it's lightning
coffee off
there
attack it
I like that I like that feature
I didn't necessarily remember it too
much
the soundtrack to Persona has always
been very unique
I've always enjoyed it it's amazing
[Music]
we never ended up using that weird body
bitter book oh yeah that one with the
muscles I wonder where we haven't used
it I get what you're saying Panther but
we'll focus one thing would be uh
further into the palace where okay
there is a place over here
that we haven't went to
oh that's
that's over here
Joker
do you live stream often
um on this channel I live stream pretty
much once a week I'm gonna start live
streaming on the aisle of my actual
personal YouTube channel
I'm gonna start doing that maybe once or
twice a week but I have been live
streaming on here at least once a week
I'm trying to be better on
playing more of the games that come out
at least giving more games an
opportunity as well especially Indie
Games I really want to do better on the
Indie field I feel like you know
IOP could do better on that on giving a
lot more Indie Games a shot
[Music]
I don't like this
oh
[Music]
this looks like boss territory
let's go save
looks like boss territory guys
we ain't trying to do boss territory
[Music]
I think you should play this indie game
called Halo infinite hey man be nice
be nice
made of a small team of death be nice
I might die from this too
it's definitely a possibility
yeah let's guard
we Garden
I don't even know what this dude's weak
to
I doubt it's guns most of the time these
big dudes ain't weeks ago
I already know the story for these Mo uh
beginning Parts Mexican
I don't need to uh read the beginning
and plus I know I'm streaming and I know
a lot of the people actually watching
don't want me to
help they don't want to be overburdened
with a bunch of dialogue as well and if
I already know the story I'm just going
to give you a small
introduction what they're actually doing
and I'm gonna keep it moving
foreign
can I put him to sleep
nope
oh he's about to
he's about to mess someone up
oh he's out of SP guys this ain't good
[Music]
all right we tried
I would say this dude weak to something
I don't have
so we're gonna have to do a bunch of
damage to him
unless he's weak to lightning no
quite the opposite I think I already
tried fire no I haven't
no
all right so he's doing this again so
let's just go ahead and not even
not even risk it
let's just let him get his little rocks
off
did a lot of damage though
the best thing we could do now is just
hit him hard as we can
do
and keep people alive as long as we
possibly can
foreign
trying to do as much damage to him as I
can
there we go
all right so that was
that that went pretty well but uh
unfortunately
I don't think we're going too much
further than that
what's funny is in the original Persona
you didn't have a grappling hook
a Persona 5 you didn't have a grappling
hook
[Music]
see it
[Music]
all right so
I wonder if I could go over there and
fight all of them if I wanted to
we're not doing that though
we're looking
for the very first opportunity we have
the next safe firm I think is a safe bet
we're we're it's a wrap at that point
there is a
can I not get back up there
I don't know if we could fight these
people
how many games have they made Persona uh
Atlas I don't know
I mean they've made five personas I know
that
they do make other games though they
don't just make persona
flame look that up for me if you don't
mind if you ain't too too busy
look how many
games that person that Atlas has made
Atlas made over 25 games so you know
they they know what they doing
[Music]
Treasure Chest spotty oh thank God I
didn't have a lock on it
all right so
I do feel like we got to get down at the
bottom it looks like they're all yellow
too
I honestly don't think we can win this
I think it's best that we retreat
pardon me foe is like the the toxic part
of me feels like I can do it
I could do it the toxic part of me is
like I could easily beat them
but the the other part of me is like fam
don't try that
so we can restore People's Health I feel
like that would be a waste currently
where we're at
and I'm trying not to waste resources
we are already in a situation where
wasting resources isn't really going to
help us
all right so I I need to get back over
there
try to make sure I get all the recess
that we possibly can
I thought I jumped down for a second oh
we have to go behind them to get back
down
[Music]
all right so let's go over here
[Music]
just grab this
I don't even know what that was to be
honest with you guys
all right all right guys
who's gonna win the toxic part of me or
the logical part of me you think I'm
gonna go down there and try to fight
these people with almost no SP no how
well I mean I got a little bit of help
so it's not like I'm gonna go in there
and just get annihilated I think I could
take out maybe one or two of them
realistically before you know
before it's a wrap
I don't know the
uh
see where this goes okay let's bring up
the map
so it looks like
we need to go up on that top right part
one of those up there got to be a safer
or we could try to go on the other side
of where we're currently at
and not get rocked
[Music]
oh it's a grappling hook
a treasure chest
[Music]
got more heavy armor
um
let's not worry about that right now
we're gonna jump over there anyway okay
because I'm a toxic individual
I don't remember these this must have
been in Persona Royal
yeah
that's come on Folk
what is it
explain yourself
what is this
just what I thought
a we'll see oh we'll see
Palace is our locations that grew
distorted from their original forms due
to their ruler's cognitions when such
distortions coalesce into form this is
the result
distortions
so what do we do
may not be as prized as a treasure but
it's still quite the rare font making it
ours will only oh so I guess they put
these in there
yeah I played um I have played this game
[Music]
I've never beat it but I have played a
good amount of this
I guess nothing happened there are more
of these around here somewhere as far as
I can tell oh there's three of them in
all
you're a cat
let's go
all right oh
[Music]
all right so that did help me a little
bit
[Music]
foreign
I hope I didn't just snatch the mask off
a red enemy
I didn't it looked like it's a yellow
enemy
[Music]
he back
but it's not a lot
so we're gonna hit the cat with this
and get rid of the oh
okay what are these things weak too
we don't have a weakness yet
[Music]
all right so there weak to the lecture
[Music]
you're still gorgeous
[Music]
okay how did more come out
yeah just do it
I don't care do it
get rid of him
a spectacular victory
all right level up level eight yeah see
I couldn't get that load those level
nine dogs
but I got the level eight
should we good
all right let's do this
we are close to the red part of the mat
I don't know if we're gonna get to it
but we are close to it
what's at the bottom
oh something we ain't fighting right now
we ain't gonna make past that dude
you notice take a note of that
all right so we are
we are at the um
the red part of the map it looks like we
are there
uh Shadow spotty it's powerful so let's
be cautious yeah I ain't trying to fight
no red thing right now none
dude
I'm not stupid I know we're gonna get
wrecked if we try to fight something red
right now
there we go
now I just gotta find a uh
wait a safe room
all right
hopefully
what is this
creepy
[Music]
Headroom let's check it out no we ain't
checking nothing out right now we
looking for a safe room
oh I need a safe room so bad
I'll reveal your true form we're about
to get killed because I don't have a
safe room
oh my God what are you weak to
please don't be win it's probably when
yeah
it's not looking good man
I hope that's safe from soon
okay
it didn't even break a sweat I don't
have any block fixed we'll have to come
back for that
there's a strong looking one up ahead oh
come on
I can't fight another red one
that's a safe room
show me your true form
hello
persona
all right so
I might be able to do this
[Music]
weaknesses okay we did find a weakness
to it
gotta do as much damage this thing as
possible
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
please put him to sleep
thank you
[Music]
I need this to go without us
thank you
yep we did it we did a chat
oh my God I was so nervous
if I was gonna die right before we got
to the to the safe room
Z
I should write something
okay
I do want to go back for that lift
I know I got to where I where I felt
comfortable going to I don't want to be
thought out on one day
in the first opportunity literally
there's like what two rooms left
I mean I guess I could keep pushing and
get to the part where you have to put
the calling card down but that ain't no
fun
is there anything here that's gonna hit
me
because I can't fight nothing
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
you notice oh it's the entrance
I don't know what free stuff you guys
are talking about I
you guys have to inform me what you mean
by free stuff
Joker's room
what are you talking about Joker's room
[Music]
all right so
I might have just screwed myself
where he sleeps oh okay
this isn't good
they put me to sleep no he didn't put me
to sleep
kill it
dead
okay
and they were too weak to bother with
all right so let's just
it's a cardboard box next to the sofa
I thought I picked that up and put it on
um
in a shelf
[Music]
oh so you can't oh yeah you have to take
the uh
this way no that's different one we have
to go over here
isn't this the intra exit yeah
it's in the Velvet Room
see what we got going for us guys
listen up
we are introducing a new record
challenge battles
depending on your results in combat you
always should you wait
challenge battles
I don't remember that
speaking to the Wardens
do you need something oh special battle
a new mode has been unlocked challenge
battles a new motor uh
battle for full moon
foggy day
oh what is this level 50.
who are these people
who's full moon are who are these people
is that the same dude no he's a
different who's
a special certain Persona user
what is that
[Music]
are these people from like the old games
or something
is the Persona 3 oh that's cool
do you fight like the key personas
do you fight the key personas that they
used in the game too
I'm not going into it you ain't catching
me dead straight fighting some Persona
users not right now
especially they say level 50 I'm level
like six
who is Trickster
trickster looks like a Persona kinda I
don't think that's a Persona user he
kind of looks like a persona
okay we ain't doing none of that I don't
want that smoke how goes the
rehabilitation
create new personas
we got the succubus
[Music]
to destruction can I get that that's the
dude on the horse
thank you
let us begin the search
terrible you okay with this you okay
with this you can't handle this
excessive power all right so these are
the possibilities of fusing
[Music]
I like this one it only leads to
destruction action
oh I'm not high enough to create it why
they even offer it to me already that's
why they shouldn't even offered it to me
no slacking if I couldn't use it don't
even offer it to me
I don't like that
yes I want to return to the world
I did I did what I told
flame I would do I got all the way to
the red parts of the map look at all
that flame
first day I went in there look at all
that flame hey
look at that
look at that flame
I didn't need to upgrade
told you I need to upgrade flame how you
feel about that
hey
I'm sorry yeah yeah yeah thank you
oh yeah okay so this is how uh
you get certain things up I get it
all right
you said there's a box
oh receipt bonus content
hi teddy costume teen glasses
[Music]
oh God there's a bunch of it gee
what are they giving me
foreign
wow
[Music]
this is a little ridiculous guys this is
just low-key pay to win I'm impressed at
a for like two minutes and I keep
getting more and more stuff